all right tonight along with millions of
Americans we do celebrate the end of the
Muller investigation and the vindication
of President Trump now we told you from
day one this was an investigation
triggered by people who wanted to undo
the results of the 2016 election we told
you week after week after week that this
probe should have never been launched
and Muller's findings of no collusion or
coordination with Russia shows that we
were right and the bitter nasty
anti-trump forces were wrong and how
wrong were they they were conspiring
with Russians a criminal conspiracy
possibly is saying that nobody in the
campaign had any contacts with Russia
false reporting is saying that there has
been no suggestion of any kind of
collusion how many more times does you
have to say the word collusion now
that's probably because he feels he
colluded yeah it's not enough to play
these sound bites and laugh although it
is fun because after these two turbulent
years America deserves more than just a
day or two a media analysis and one fair
headline from the New York Times today
America deserves to know what really
happened here the forces the individuals
and the motivations behind this total
travesty of justice and we must ensure
that those responsible face real
political legal and professional
repercussions we can never let this
happen to another president again I can
tell you that I say it very strongly
very few people I know could have
handled it
we can never ever let this happen to
another president again these past 675
days were filled with unfair slanderous
defamatory vicious irresponsible and
erroneous reporting and commentary about
this president and also about his
current and former staff and yes his
family there was activities with the
Trump campaign and Russia and some of
that was jarred Kushner's
responsibilities some of it was Donald
Jr I think you're gonna probably see
indictments of both of those people we
we know that Don
Trump jr. and Eric Trump have bragged
about how much money the Trump
Organization has gotten out of Russia
anytime there was collusion going on
Donny was there just sad sticky wad of
congealed hair jealous spent his whole
life seeking his dad's approval and
failing at it and now he might be the
one to bring down
Trump's presidency Oh Samantha be best
well throughout the show we're gonna be
naming names in the Russia Investigation
Hall of Shame we will not forget and
neither should you those who acted and
spoke with such a reckless disregard of
the truth and basic standards of
professionalism there must be a
reckoning it's time to hold government
officials reporters pundits media
executives and yes politicians
accountable for their role in this
Russia hoax now we start with the Russia
hoax political Hall of Shame and why not
begin with senator tricky dick
Blumenthal from my home state of
Connecticut now this was them when he
could talk only of the possible Moscow
trumped our deal and Russian collusion
the project never happened but not for
lack of trying and not for lack of
desire the Russians knew that he was
lying American people they enabled him
and now they have that leverage over him
so he's compromised
who's compromised now dick but now at
the end of the Muller probe Blumenthal
must realize that there was no Russian
leverage over the president right
Shirley's changed his tune
the facts and evidence here are likely
to show a lot of criminality
a lot of wrongdoing and law breaking
that is not indicted here okay he was a
state attorney general by the way for
our second entry let's move on to Mad
Max scene shall we now do you remember
what she said back in 2017 this
president and his allies I believe and
others believed colluded with the
Russians to undermine our democracy and
we're not gonna stop talking about it
all I know is this if he thinks he can
stop me from talking about impeach 45
he's got another thought coming I am not
intimidated by him I'm gonna keep saying
that we need to impeach him but what is
she saying now here's aunty Maxine
yesterday he's been saying no collusion
no collusion no collusion over and over
again for a long time now and he's going
to try and conclude that there this
report is proving that there's no
collusion and you have a lot of his
sycophants who will you know take the
nod from him and they'll say the same
thing but we cannot allow them to get
away with this okay so let me get this
straight Maxine so now Andrew Weissman
and Bob Muller are all part of a pro
Trump conspiracy with what like
conservative journalists our third entry
in the political Hall of Shame goes to
Ben and Jerry Nadler I mean Jerry
Nellore how did it get in there surely
an elder statesman like Jerry has a
different view here he was just a few
months ago it's become very clear that
the Trump campaign colluded with the
Russians in trying to subvert the
election the president is right to be
nervous right now because it appears
that the time is running out when he can
hold himself above the law now we know
though now that neither the president
nor anyone in his orbit was indicted for
colluding with Russia so I bet Nadler
sees things differently now right we
know there was some collusion but none
of what you just said has opened to the
level of a criminal indictment by the
official counsel no it hasn't
as far as we know but we know there was
collusion why there's been no
indictments we don't know you believe
the president has obstructed justice you
still believe that well there have been
obstruction of justice whether there
clearly whether there are criminal
obstructions and other questions is it
takes your breath away
there was no obstruction found two years
of investigation sir but of course he
says there is obstruction what there's
no criminal collusion found but he says
we know there is collusion
what forth on the list crazy mazie
Hirono here she is last year on
presidential pardons for him to come out
to say that he could pardon himself and
know some of the other outrageous
statements he's making he thinks he's a
dictator and a king it shows that that
he's really afraid of what the Muller
investigation will show is so after
everything we learned over the weekend
she's doing a Maher culpa now right just
because there was not enough evidence
for a criminal charge of conspiracy does
not mean that there's a very cozy
relationship that Donald Trump has with
louder Putin now what's the cosy
standard as I always say being a liberal
means never having to say you're sorry
she's just acting like I don't know old
Eric swallow well who frankly makes me
unwell for months he's painted a
portrait of the president that could
have been ripped from a Mario Puzo novel
it's so obvious that they were eager to
collude with Russia now we're seeing the
evidence that there was a conspiracy to
cover up it's looking more and more wolf
that Donald Trump was a part of a
criminal campaign a criminal transition
and now presides over a criminal
presidency okay so after the Attorney
General special counsel cleared the
president of wrongdoing he's changed his
mind right I think the American people
want to know whether this president
violated conduct while whether he
violated not only the law but that honor
code that we all count on wait a second
now honor code is the president now like
a member of a Cub Scout troop
did he break the law or not Muller after
two years said he did not but sois well
like shameless Adam Schiff can't let go
of their old narratives could certainly
say with confidence that there is
significant evidence of collusion
between the campaign and Russia there's
a very real prospect that on the day
Donald Trump leaves office the Justice
Department may indict him that he may be
the first president in quite
time to face the real prospect of jail
time nope wrong there are no grounds to
indict him because as Muller said there
was no collusion between the president
the Trump campaign and the Russians so
you did read the bar letter didn't you
Adam there's still a lot of reason to be
concerned about this president's
relationship with Russia and Putin
Republicans should note here the
tenacity of these people even when they
were proven completely wrong they double
down and press their case again and
again and again
imagine what Republicans could do with
that kind of commitment all these
Democrats showed hideously flawed
judgment and each and every one of them
though should face primary challenges
absolutely Kelly and Conway took it
further today you have Adam Schiff he
believes that the scandal was of a size
and a scope probably bigger than
Watergate and that there's plenty of
evidence of collusion he ought to resign
today
he's been on every TV show fifty times a
day for practically the last two years
promising Americans that this president
would either be impeached or indicted
these Democrats and many more made a
cataclysmic mistake they spent countless
hours on TV giving speeches they were
pronouncing the end of the Trump
presidency
literally accusing him of seditious
behavior I don't think a lot of them
even believed what they were saying but
they didn't care hating Trump became its
own competitive sport on the left and in
the meantime Trump kept pushing forward
growing the economy appointing great
judges trying to untangle red tape kill
regulations that suffocate expansion and
innovation in business but the Democrats
well they left their own party
unattended although they did well in the
midterms let's face it and they won back
the house a lot of that was anti Trump
stuff fed by the rush of falsehoods
substantial workable ideas were few and
far between
well what did this do this created a
vacuum ideas vacuum in the Democrat
Party which left the door open to
socialism
which the freshmen radicals walked right
through so what did two years of bashing
Trump really get them even after the
Muller report they're threatening more
hearings but otherwise Democrats are on
the defensive with infighting in the
ranks fending off charges of
anti-semitism as their new young
radicals embrace collectivism that's for
president Trump he should take this
moment as an opportunity to reset and
relaunch his presidency free of the
albatross of the Russia investigation
it's now time to take it all into high
gear
strike a good deal with China if one can
be had get this border sealed build as
much of that wall as you can task ice to
find those illegals already subject to
removal orders and deport him that in
and of itself will have a great
deterrent effect at the border show the
country that the left wasn't just wrong
on Russia they were wrong on just about
everything go to the inner cities go to
the blue states expand this movement
show your heart you're charming and have
fun winning is fun now gloating won't
get you reelected and neither will the
Muller Report but your record of success
properly framed and explained that will
which may be the best reckoning of all
and that's the angle